[Musik]
ich bin von der vorne gekommen ich
dachte mir schon dass es wahrscheinlich
irgendwas jetzt mit corona zu tun hat
[Musik]
ich dachte erst es ginge um
sonderangebote eines geschäfts wegen der
farben aber wir laufen halten auch mit
was gelogen man erkennt sich nicht mehr
wirklich gut erfolg das herz muss ich
wirklich sagen elf uhr am vormittag vor
dem kölner dom 111 schaufensterfiguren
baute künstler dennis josef mesic mit
seinem team auf dem roncalliplatz auf
ots leitet ist hat er seine installation
genannt zu deutsch es ist wie es ist ein
sinnbild für die korona pandemie und
deren gesellschaftliche auswirkungen und
steht für die bewegungseinschränkungen
die wipo coroner zeiten haben dass wir
nicht das tun können uns nicht so
bewegen können wie wir es gewohnt sind
wie wir es gerne gesehen gerade in
krisenzeiten wie sich unser leben ändern
kann und errungenschaften die wir als
selbstverständlich empfunden haben auf
einmal in so weiter ferne rücken die
domplatte in köln ist einer von vielen
orten an denen der künstler seine puppen
inszeniert seit beginn der pandemie im
vergangenen jahr sind diese bereits
durch mehr als 30 deutsche städte geburt
unter anderem machten sie vor dem
berliner reichstag reiz
[Musik]
eroberten potsdam und besetzten die alte
lahnbrücke in lindow die in rot weißes
flatterband eingewickelten figuren
symbolisieren die soziale distanz und
den stillstand des öffentlichen lebens
selbst auf einer skipiste die figuren
kommen aus allen himmelsrichtungen wie
kommen zum beispiel auch aus boutiquen
aus allen richtungen die ihre pforten
geschlossen haben über die korona zeit
aber auch ein hobby baumarkt dazu machen
musste dort konnte ich dann alle figuren
für einen sehr vernünftigen preis
erwerben
dennis josef mäßig studiert an der
alanus hochschule für kunst und
gesellschaft in der nähe von bonn
sein spezialgebiet sind skulpturen aus
materialien wie holz das er mit einer
kettensäge bearbeitet oder
metallkonstruktionen it is like it ist
ist seine erste öffentliche installation
noch in diesem jahr soll ein fotoband
über die schaufensterpuppen erscheinen
die stellvertretend das erleben was
vielen während der pandemie nicht
möglich ist sie gehen in clubs machen
gesellige abende oder einen ausflug in
den zoo zuletzt feierten die puppen in
köln ausgiebig karneval der zum bedauern
vieler jecken ausfallen musste zum
vergleich so sah das noch im vergangenen
jahr aus
dass die touren der installation
unabhängig von ruhenden kunst und kultur
betrieben stattfinden kann ist nicht nur
glück sondern auch botschaft der kunst
und kultur ist natürlich auch was fürs
oberstübchen was man vielleicht gar
nicht bewusst so mitbekommt was einen
geistig anregt inspiriert auch in
anderen lebensbereichen und das merkt
man jetzt vielleicht irgendwas einem das
halt irgendwie fehlt im mai wird dennis
josef mäßig für it is like it is mit dem
kreativitäts preis creo in zürich
ausgezeichnet
und wenn es die pandemie zulässt will er
mit seinen schaufensterpuppen bald auch
durch andere länder touren
[Musik]